[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host scroll and this video we're
breaking down secret Invasion Episode 2.
this entry has some of my favorite
acting scenes in the MCU when we get
some incredible back and forth between
some other characters there's the one
scene on the train with Nick and Talos
the one with Nick and Rowdy and that
interrogation scene before we get a big
ending there's lots of Easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed as
well and a number of comic book
callbacks at time with the books now
after scenes from Captain Marvel we pick
right up in Brixton during 1997 which is
where we meet a younger graphic Brixton
thematically reflects a key theme in the
show with the Scrolls being a metaphor
for refugees and migrants if you're
watching this in America then you might
not be aware but there's this big thing
that's gone on the last couple of years
called the Windrush Scandal now I've
tried to do as much research as I could
with the time we have for the video and
I reached out to social commentator
Michael Morgan who's talked about what's
happening with this quite a lot there's
lots of things to go over but I think
it's clearly used as the bases here and
as I go through the history let me know
if you agree now to give you a bit of a
brief history back in 1948 the HMT
Empire Windrush brought several Jamaican
civilians over who settled in the area
in 1998 Brixton library was renamed
Windrush Square to commemorate 50 years
of them making their home in Britain now
I don't think it's a coincidence that
this was picked as the place we open up
at but sadly the real life story had its
controversies too the Windrush Scandal
studded in 2018 and involved wrongly
detaining those from the Windrush
generation and denying them of their
rights even though some of the people
had lived here for over 70 years we
ended up getting 83 cases where people
were wrongly deported and this was
carried out by the UK's home office lots
of people were forced to resign there
was a hell of a lot of controversy and
it all basically came out looking really
bad for the country now of course also
have Sonia falsworth in the show who
works with MI6 and I actually think that
Brixton might pop up later on London's
been shown in the title sequence and it
appears later in the episode so I'm
thinking that Brixton might be where
things end up going down now this might
be me drawing connections that weren't
initially intentional but personally I
took Brixton as being picked for that
reason like the Scrolls the migrants
were promised compensation and Aid once
the government's policies got hit with
backlash but these promises like Furies
have never came to be might be a reach
and whenever I touch upon political
commentary in a video you always get the
backlash of people saying keep politics
out this stuff might not be intentional
but yeah I think it is worth touching
upon and that's how I took it with us
starting off year either way let me know
your thoughts below and all that and as
we discussed 1997's the air that I think
we need to talk about now Not only was
it the other and oh ah just a little bit
a little bit more both those got
released but it's also when Fury started
putting things into action Carol left
with the Scrolls back in 1995 and she
said that she was gonna find them all a
brand new home two years later they
still haven't been given one but Fury
says they can stay on Earth if they help
a mountain Shield
they're gonna become his spies hit the
thumbs up button for him and work for
him as soldiers so he can get something
back now if you look at the comics we
can actually see why the Scrolls wanted
to take Earth and make it their new home
during the cree scroll war skrillos was
destroyed and thus they looked to find a
new place located in the universe ton X4
had become the capital but they still
didn't feel like it was where they
really belonged now the comics had
several ancient prophecies that
predicted what would happen with the
species and when you hear them you'll
understand why they thought the Earth
was theirs the first was that Galactus
would destroy the planet and this came
to be alongside the Creek School War an
ex-pot of the prophecy said that they'd
make their home a blue planet and with
Earth being a focal point that's where
they set their sights now here they
initially see it as a refuge and due to
being displaced they've moved to Earth
because it offers them protection
they're able to integrate get jobs and
help Nick furya with a dangling carrot
being that they'll have a home
eventually they're also fleeing war and
persecution from the cree with gravic's
parents dying during one of the big
battles with them graphic escaped from
Behind Enemy Lines and piloted ship out
there which explains why so many who
look to him as a leader Fury says this
is a child
only to humanize and this also plays in
how the Scrolls age slower than humans
last week we had this bit with Talos not
bad for 136 year old wow yeah not even
40 in human years and so it shows how
he's probably older than Nick Fury
enlists him into his army and you can
kind of see why he feels used because
all these scrolls are given jobs in
Espionage so that they can help him out
now at one point he puts his head to
gravic's head and this is something we
saw last week when he met up with Talos
his calls back to the Captain Marvel
movie when Talus was reunited with his
family and he did the same thing when he
met back up with his wife now an
important car to meet here is also who
we see at the end has become Nick Fury's
wife known as Clara she takes in the
name Priscilla and becomes fully
integrated with us humans along with
several others bringing children into
his war is a big No-No but it shows
there's no bounds in his top priorities
at security now the reason that they
might hate Talus as well is because of
what he says here and he he's clearly
the one selling that Furies their savior
this man
I trust it's sort of like Scott's tots
and Furious just making promises that he
can't keep the end of one division show
that he'd been working with his Scrolls
but now we know that this has been going
on for the last couple of decades now
the Scrolls sort of integrated in with
their society in the comics but it was
done to other means that were let's say
less than Savory their first appearance
was back in Fantastic Four issue 2 where
they tried to take over the Earth and
were eventually defeated now rather than
killing them the first family put
something in place so that they were all
hypnotized to think that they were cows
since then they've just roamed the field
and they use this as a nice way to sort
of lobotomize them but maybe not ice but
moving on now hypnosis is how they've
always been brought in and there's also
been times where they've been made to
become firefighters emergency service
workers and people who can help us out
rather than trying to attack us The
Postman Pat probably a scroll and we
later learn how hard they've worked
their way up natalus's wife is the first
to step forward as part of this cause
and this is him sort of using them to
show they can be trusted politics tend
to get their families involved in
controversial things to show that it's
safe because they put the people they
love in it it's a tactic that gets lots
of people to join up but we see how this
is being fractured by Fury's final words
which then transition over brilliantly
you keep your word I'll keep mine
[Music]
just love watching the cut from that to
the Elder gravic who's now become a
terrorist attacking us on Earth huge
allowed to Emin to that who last week
committed saying that there's a reason
here why he's the perfect villain it was
said that Fury used to be three steps
ahead but Graphics actually been three
steps ahead this entire time this is why
he changed into three people in the last
episode and the scene that happens here
of course builds off the back of it Fury
almost finds a hell to die on and we
watch while it's a scroll Warrior plays
his pop brilliantly I'm an American I'm
an American he's clearly trying to
incite a war by saying this repeatedly
and it's the main thing that pushes us
to turn against each other reminded me a
lot of the no Russian Mission from Call
of Duty which two used a similar way to
rise tensions in the world Fury's
grabbed by talas and as we see later on
this Scrolls being grabbed by the
Russians now from here we go to the
title sequence which if you've been on
Twitter the last week you'll have seen
there was a lot of anger over being done
by AI I actually think with its usage
here that you can argue it has its
merits because the show is about people
being replaced by something that can
easily copy them that's how I took it
anyway and I know the creative team
hired people to work on it so it's not
like people were losing their jobs
because of it the credits have a number
of people listed as handling the titles
who used AI to help create this and then
altered it from there backlash got so
bad that method Studios even put out a
statement saying that animators employed
AI with it being used for the show
central theme they also said while the
AI components provided optimal results
AI is just one tool among the array of
tool sets are artists used no artist
jobs were replaced by incorporating
these new tools instead they
complemented and assisted our creative
is an AI he's an A.I get it
so yeah let me know below what you think
and after that we go to Fury and Talos
hiding on a train disguised as a woman
he manages to talk the gods down and we
get a nice little line giving a wink to
the audience now in the car Fury
recounts his story about his past and
the games used to play along with his
mother this is similar to the winter
solgen which he talked about his
grandfather's life and how that made him
realize how he had to up security you
know they used to play music
yeah my grandfather operated one of
these things for 40 years in both
instances they use it here to make the
other character open up with Fury
bringing up a game here so tell us
starts to tell him things tell me
something I don't know about the
destruction of Scrolls
he recalls eating deviled eggs which had
the earliest known American recipe
printed back in Montgomery in 1877. see
he said he was leaving Alabama and going
to eat eggs which is a literal Easter
egg that I bet Ryanair he didn't get
maybe this is called maybe he is I've
been saying it for years he's a
scrolling but no one believed this shut
the [__] up Ryan Airy oh you relax here
this is just getting to something like
Fury story leading to learning the full
extent of the invasion this adds to the
backstory of his early life in Alabama
which he also told to Carol back in
Captain Marvel he also talks about
segregation and how he and his mother
weren't allowed any of the cars which
symbolically represents how the Scrolls
have been held back coming out of
Alabama we always had to ride in the
color car Talos reveals though that he's
actually been playing his own games and
how he's brought over millions who now
live on the planet uncheck this could
cause a major load of trouble especially
because they can look like us and
replace all of our leaders we also hear
about the destruction of scrollos as
well which Talos seems to tell well I
think there's definitely some missing
info here and we'll probably learn what
really happened as the show goes on
seems like there's way more complexity
to it due to the meeting with the
council and if they brought in Galactus
that would that would be pretty mental
that was gonna happen but he does
mention the emperor and also that he has
a colony and every scroll that isn't in
Emperor George's colony and the answer
this is similar to the comics but
instead knows he was named emperadoric
now before the events of secret Invasion
the Illuminati actually went to him and
told him to lay off Earth before things
stud escalate to the point that they
were just gonna wipe them out dark said
that because they'd insulted him in his
home that he was now gonna make it his
prime target and the Illuminati
attempted to kill him before they fled
into the Stars caught and captured they
were then experimented on which could
tease something that's coming in the
show with gravic we later had Skrill
Empress varanke who would go on to take
over an impersonate Jessica Drew Norman
Osborne killed her and he then got seen
as a hero in the eyes of the rest of
humanity he was made the director of
shield and given unprecedented Powers
which could be hinting at things coming
in the show we of course have President
written who we saw in episode 1 but we
know that Harrison Ford's going to be
playing president Ross potentially he's
the one who brings it down and takes out
the major scroll threat and then he's
voted into power over the president down
the line I also think it's possible a
president might be a scroll too and him
being outed would mean a new one has to
come in and Talos admits his plan was to
interrogate the Scrolls on Earth and
that rather moving on he just wanted to
coexist Fury says there's not enough
room or Tolerance on this planet or
another species can you stop yelling at
me please no I can't stop yelling cause
that's how I talk you ain't never seen
my movies sorry don't know how that got
in there but yeah I have to say yeah I
thought this scene was brilliant Fury is
always being kind of stoic and I felt
like he's in control whereas here we can
see the fury is completely Furious could
the London again and we see Maria Hill's
body being brought in which is where we
meet her mother Elizabeth for the first
time Kobe smolders has said that we're
gonna Explore More Maria's backstory in
the series so we might see more stuff
with Elizabeth or learn that she's alive
an interesting thing about this show is
that Disney released a list of things he
needed to watch before this and amongst
it was the non-cunning show Agents of
Shield Fury features in there I know
they wiped it clean there's potentially
a clue there too about what's going on
with Maria in the comics Fury went to
her when he discovered that there were
Scrolls and said that she should start
employing lmds in case you don't know
these are life model decoys which are
highly Advanced robots that are meant to
mimic humans they copy someone's brain
thought process and so on and so forth
and can be sent in a dangerous
situations when the person's acting
cautious lmd showed up in Agents of
Shield as well and they became a major
part of the Arsenal so maybe that
explains the way that Hill could
possibly come back personally I'd prefer
if she was dead sorry love as I think it
takes away from the stakes and it just
works better if that final scene has
some sense of finality now lmds are a
big part of the comics and Theory
employed them throughout most of his
life I've just reread original sin and
in that we discovered that the infinity
formula that kefir young had worn off
and that he'd been rapidly aging the
heroes came across an old withered
version of him and thus the new theory
is in that everyone's a scroll it's at
everyone's in lmd you're an OMD I'm an
lmd Mephisto he's a [__] lmd now
Fury's having to face up to his failures
again and Maria's mother says that she
believed in him again he's letting
people down not living up to what he
once was which is something reflected in
the Scrolls and also in Infinity war
from here we go to the news which is
filled with several different reports
and normally I'd go to a sponsor this
week but we don't have one I feel like
we should sponsor ourselves though and
let you know that we've got a secret
Invasion inspired t-shirt over at our
merch store shop zeroedition.com is
where we sell lots of nerdy inspired
clothing and it helps support the
channel and makes all listeners not look
like Chumps the clouds are all made with
high quality fabrics and they're also
designed to help accentuate the best
parts of your body the prints are high
quality too and they don't just
disappear after they've been washed
really nice clothes wear them every day
not even joking so head over to
shopzeroedition.com spoil yourself and
get some amazing merch you lucky piece
of [__] give me a rent from here we go
to some news reports with a BBC parody
called CUV news there's also an oien
parody and one ripping on Fox with us
seeing several key characters here that
show up on the council the leader of
NATO is one the UK's prime minister and
the fxn host who's played by Christopher
McDonald he says there's no way that
Moscow attack was committed by Americans
and this will of course instantly put
America's guard up and make tensions
rise now we've had a lot of different
Prime Ministers over the years in
England so if you told me one was a
scroll I'd be like yeah checks it's it's
bloody him it also can't be overstated
how much news influences people so the
scrolls are clearly slotting into key
power position is actually riffs on the
comics quite a bit as we get a moment
where the Scrolls appear on screens as
several prominent figures this includes
Barack Obama Oprah Winfrey Chris Rock
Paris Hilton and even Tom Cruise
wouldn't put pastel out there's there's
Stephen Colbert but there's many many
more and it shows how they've seeped
into every aspect of life now the UK
being infiltrated could also be a nod to
the Russia report which was set up to
see the scale of Russian interference in
several of our votes it's a big fear
right now that the show plays upon
perfectly and I love when we met the
council and we saw they were all in
positions of power graphic detests them
for Bowing to men and using our culture
so that they can stand back and just
hide in the shadows the other roles are
not revealed with the credits listing
the names is Shirley Saga and Jack
huckman I had seen some reports saying
that Tony Kern who played borenth or the
Dark World was the UK PM so perhaps
you'll end up taking over when Theresa
Mays revealed he was the guy we saw
Sonia talking to by the bug and her
office yes so the casting list could be
wrong as it often is now one could
presume he's an MI6 agent and totally
ridiculous insane due time he's been
fished out no I'm joking he's he's
Captain Britain ridiculous I know but
that's the end of the insane Theory time
oh either way they held a vote over
whether Graphics should be put in charge
during peace time democracy is fine but
in times of War you need to unite behind
one leader gravic has of course caused
the War as people don't know what's
going on and in his quest for power he's
created bloodthirsty Scrolls now Scrolls
and the comics are of course the
villains but Captain Marvel flip the
script to make them appear sympathetic
here it's come full circle though with
them going back to their Warrior ways
and deciding to use their abilities to
seize their own power only one member
says no but gravic refuses to kill her
and he says you're gonna be sister
however later on we see that he doesn't
mind doing it even after rescuing his
Warrior he still takes him at his
punishment Because deep down he knows
that they talked still though he's
clearly willing to do it if he has to
but he probably won't do it here because
he knows that these people hold the
power now they also question what
happens if the Avengers turn up and once
again that takes us right into dude
I told you we were doing a baby with big
so later on in the episode Gaia comes
across a secret operation in new Scrolls
where we see several different names
pulling from the MCU they have files on
Groot color obsidian and also Frost
beasts as well as extremis guessing that
groot's Twigs were found at the site in
wakanda and the frost Beast came down
during Thor the Dark World Cole's hand
can be seen there too and this was of
course found after it got severed off we
also see her bring a beta which shows a
strand of his DNA showing that they've
got things like that mapped out to
perhaps do some experiments during the
interrogation we also get this line too
building a machine what kind of machine
he gets to make us stronger now we
mentioned this a few times but Scrolls
can only change their appearance to look
like superheroes and they don't gain the
powers that come along with it and this
was something that changed in the comics
when all the Avengers got captured and
they spent years studying their DNA to
try and mimic their abilities now I
don't know if you've seen Westworld
before mate because I don't know you I
don't want to know you but I don't know
you uh but you might remember a bit in
that where they kept resurrecting James
delos through using Ai and the host
bodies they ran Fidelity tests to see
whether they could bring someone back to
life and make a copy of them by
downloading their brain and that's
something that the Scrolls sort of did
with read riches as he was held captive
and they started to make clones waking
up in hospital believing that he was the
original they'd have Scrolls come in and
pretend to be his family however he
eventually always hit a point where he
realized that they were Scrolls and they
had to take him out because he could
just go mental either way though they
were trying to mimic his powers and in
the end they eventually managed to do it
this let them masquerade as The Avengers
without anyone getting wise because as
soon as someone questioned them they
just show off their power set it appears
this is the program that the Scrolls
will use to make a version of the super
scroll which will come with all the
powers that the names and these files
say in the trailer for the show we see
gravity Growers on like grutas which
makes it clear that they've been
harvesting their powers a cool obsidian
had his arm cut off during the first few
fights of infinity war and extremis or
Ames files wouldn't be that hot for
Scrolls to find we actually saw an
extremis user pop up in the golden
dagger Club in chongqi so they may be
trying to get those regenerating
properties as well now it appears that
gravic will be one of the first to gain
powers and be just like the super scroll
that appeared in the comics introduced
in Fantastic 4 18 the super scroll was
created to get revenge on Marvel's first
family after they thwarted them in
Fantastic Four two clear the super
scroll had all the powers of the
Fantastic Four but was ultimately bested
and trapped in a volcano so I kind of
feel like that's what's going on here
and it would make a match for The
Avengers which is why gravic says not to
worry about them anyway we cut to the
plant and I realized they're making
plants they can put in government and
doing this at the plant anyway gravics
surrounded by prominent Scrolls here
which of links to the comics and also
the behind the scenes stuff Beto could
be named after be the dentist and this
is actually a staff writer on the show
Pagan is played by Killian Scott and
this was the scroll that took over the
body of Elektra lastly Krieger is played
by arima chicka chickova and she's
someone who's a super scroll in the
Marvel mangaverse also going back to 97
at the start I wonder if these Scrolls
could pop up in the Animated Series
X-Men 97 I digress though and from here
we go to a meeting which is when we hear
a news reporter then saying this the 27
EU heads of state plus the British prime
minister so brexit happened in the MCU
to keep things closer to our world and
the Nations have gathered to start
grilling Roadie boom they're looking for
Nick asking him whether the US was
involved in what happened now in Russia
he also says slovaki rolls the size of
me one more time I'm gonna put on the
suit and carpet vomit why are you here
which is a move that we saw him pulling
off in Infinity War
this came from the future to add this
one more thing to the video and I'm also
wearing our scroll fiction t-shirt on
shopzeredition.com celebrating the
series so one thing that I just noticed
when I was making this video is that Don
Cheadle first appeared in Iron Man 2
getting a bit of a grilling and that's
also happening here at this point in the
series interesting as well Don Cheadle
yeah his roadie he's went from working
alongside the government everything
changed in Infinity War when he told
General Ross to do one and now he's back
on the questioning so just something to
notice that oh no the future is pulling
me back and one thing Rody says is that
the US is the most powerful Nation on
Earth but wakanda is probably looking
over like bruh kind of reminds me of
that scene when romondi shut them down
and wakanda forever and it leads into an
incredible territor between Nick Fury
and Rowdy Don Cheadle completely knocks
it at the park here and we learned that
Nick's not the only one who's used
Scrolls for his security the US has used
them too and I couldn't help thinking
this might be a metaphor for conflicts
of the past the US has helped out
several groups in their private Wars and
in a lot of cases they've turned around
and went against the country we also
know that real world incidents affected
the plot of the show itself and they
actually shot elements of it due to
being similar to the war in Ukraine
anyway back to the scene and the
discussion between Rowdy is very very
interesting we get a call back to
Alexander Pierce and as you'll recall he
was the villain of the Winter Soldier
Hydra had infiltrated several aspects of
the government and this is similar to
how the Scrolls have started sneak into
we learned that it's not just Fury that
new of the Scrolls as another craft
crash landed out in the US I'm guessing
this was part of the million Scrolls
answering the call left by Talos which
might have drawn in more than the
million that he knows about also
discussed in table is the idea of
reaching out to the Avengers Rowdy
mentions calling their friends but then
Fury quickly shuts this down he says
they haven't got the budget to have them
and though he says they they risk them
being captured and turned into
terrorists which is something that also
happened in the secret Invasion comics
in their own Tony was a director of
Shield but come the Andy got kicked out
because of the Scrolls potentially
posing as him makes sense as it would be
catastrophic for someone like Captain
America to be shown attacking civilians
and it could speak to the idea of deep
fakes and fake news this means that Fury
is truly alone firstly being blamed for
the dirty bomb losing Maria Hill and now
parting ways with Talos although how
Fury gets taken out though and he shows
he's still got it as he sorts out the
security guard and then disarms his gun
I'm Nick Fury
even when I'm out
I'm in and from here we get this on your
filesworth making one hell of an
entrance watching Olivia Coleman tear
this stuff up so good to see and if I
compliment her anymore I'll probably go
and spoil it all by saying something
stupid like I like you
I mean not that
asking where the escape hatch is this
comes in handy later and she starts by
cutting off fingers before getting to
work an interesting thing that you might
catch here another clouds are purple and
green these are of course colors of the
Scrolls so that could be a little hint
that it's not all As It Seems secondly
she has a syringe that appears to make
someone's bloodlet really boil and this
could be similar to extremist reactions
just before people explode however as an
agent of shield fan I see blue liquid
and I instantly started thinking that
this is actually Cree blood this is used
in Project Tahiri and it helped bring
Coulson back from the dead after he was
killed by Loki Tahiti is a magical place
and they may even do something similar
to bring back Maria Hill Cree blood has
regenerative effects and this is why it
was also used to bring back Carol
Danvers however with a scroll it
possibly has the opposite effect as they
don't have a stable state so instead it
just burns for them and one thing I
don't get about Scrolls right in listen
here so they copy clothes and last week
this guy mimicked the guy's heart rate
in that ritual and we even seen him copy
his [__] and vest so when we could do
this and he's not wearing the shirt but
he's wearing the vest when he took off
the shirt did like did his skin go with
him can scrolled forms clothes yeah and
can they then take that off probably a
crap question to ask yeah but we're
trying to get to the bottom of it and
Sonia makes her Escape as graphic and
Cole closing however she does learn the
name of the couple working on the
experiments and that she now has a way
to go and track them down graphic grabs
his guy so he can't spill any more
secrets and they brutally take out the
Russian forces to clean up all the mess
murdering around the woods you can see
it really messes up Gaia as he knows
she's in even more danger now Judah her
betraying him anyway we end with Fury
going to one of his storage lockers
which looks like it's located in Jolly
Old London traveling out to his wife we
find them living in the British
Countryside as Fury has to drive on the
correct side of the road the correct one
now in his house we see several coats
hanging up up as well as black and white
art that looks like a mixture of people
in abstract shapes it's clear why his
wife would want this as well as it's
similar to a scroll and it's nice to see
him pause and look at it before he comes
in now last week he told Talos that he
knew better looking skrulls than him so
I'm guessing that he was talking about
his wife now everyone's gonna be like
well he might describe crazy married a
scroll but I tell you if I a new one
even if it was a dude I'd be on it till
I vomit imagine right you've got a wife
who's a shape-shifter you can come home
to Anna diaris on a Monday you know what
I mean Dua LIPA on a Tuesday Hayley out
well on a Wednesday young Alicia Keys
God damn now I can't wait to see if we
learn what's actually going on with them
since 1997. Nick [__] Scrolls
actually has president in the comics
because he of course spent the night
with Valentina in a I'm not judging I've
woken up to worse clearly though he's
been doing some things to keep her out
of danger and this includes hiding his
wedding ring and leaving it at home this
is so that people never Target her to
try to get to him and it makes sense
when you're a secret spy now this is why
it's left in the house and in the
background here are this is reading song
Try a Little Tenderness you may
recognize it as being sampled on Jay-Z
and Kanye West's track other Sunny came
from the album called Watch the Throne
the Embrace is also rather similar in a
way to Steven Peggy dancing too it's
been a long long time as both scenes
feature arena in a loving couple anyway
that ends the entry and I loved seeing
him going home to plot and plan what's
next Priscilla being a scroll can also
help him out but he might just want to
spend some time with her there at his
side now those are my thoughts on this I
enjoyed last week but I thought this was
better and really enjoy the escalation
and things that played out like I said
this had three really solid scenes in it
with characters going back and forth and
then juking it out really enjoyed it
again and I think this might be my
favorite MC show so far if we're judging
off the first two episodes compare to
everything else it's a big Jet Set
Adventure that makes you feel like it's
worldwide and it's hammered home by
brilliant performances carried out by
the cast again Samuel L Jackson feels
like he's knocking out of the park and
this is really Fury with his back
against the wall really enjoyed it and I
know people are having issues with this
show but I think it's down to what you
like and what you want to see let me see
if this is any kind of thing then it's
it's you're not gonna enjoy it but
there's someone who finds stuff like
this good I thought they continued to
kill it either way let me know your
thoughts below and if there's anything
we missed then make sure you point it
out if you want to support the channel
for as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you you'll get early access
to videos every week have you won
something else to watch who got a secret
Invasion video on screen right now
talking about when exactly it was that
Everett Ross got changed we have a good
three times on it we have a lot of fun
so definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
singing through the video I've been Paul
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
said that piece